今にちょエアー小慣れだ
在庫処分って感じでは前回動画でちゃんキロのドライアイスを使ってその滑れるかどう
かで実験したんですけど
もったいないんだよねだからちょっと申し訳ないんですけどもう1本
もう作りますあれから約1週間奪った訳なんですけどもいいくらいアイスが結構小さく
なりました
第十分の一眼って言うねぇ
10キロずっキロぐらいだと思います10キロもう author
ドライアイスつったらこれしかないわけよこの浴槽にマンつに熱い熱湯入れてその
ネッド中にドライアイス10分を叩き込みます
はいわからないですまたメインかサブかわかんないです
いやもうこの動画は勝ってる地点でメインかサブ勝手がわかるんですけどまだ俺はいけ
ないぞ
弁当
見れるジャズバーってなんて1時なんでねぇバーガー
バーンバーンがーだったら
バーンなるカラーよりあー坊屋さんたすけて高いけど
キュリーちゃーっ俺的には
わあああああんがーどうぞ
アーちゃんアー白する
ああああああ
何とかわかんないけど10キロのドラ s のでそう準備できないですから
じゃあを入れますちょっとごめんで床が汚れててさ
色々あった理由は最初は緩いのが出るからちょっと逃してから入ってます
はいてるけど今待ってます
tan
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
ん
[音楽]
洋酒
第1敗でしょ入れます実はに取らないんですねえ
これなんか小さくで10キロな1勝って見えるけどとりあえずめちゃくちゃ重いからね
こういうところで全然思いしてこれ
10キロだと思う全体10キロ早速じゃあねっとなぁ弾いてみようと思います今回これ
でもうメインチャンネルがサブチャネルはっきり分かれるから
じゃあ行きます水2
わー fire fire
ん
zombie-loan
ちょっん
逃げろやばい逃げろ
えっ
rar
ちょっと変わった
んじゃないといいです映画に出てきたんですけど走ってもいいです
右上米が侵略されてきますゆい
えっ
me
day
san
ええええええ
n アツッ
ちょっと払えないと1回とします
やばい俺長屋なんかライブ会場みたいなちょっとはじゃないぞ
やばいライブ解除
ん
持って
これこれやばくていいかなぁ
ちょっと待て
全体的にヤバいん
[音楽]
ライブの毛女ってこういう感じですねきっと
らんどまーさんもいつもご苦労様です
じゃあさっそくない
ドライアイスの本拠地を開けてみましょう
[拍手]
メインチャンネルで
[音楽]